Humiliation... we've all experienced
it at some point in our lives,
or we've done it to others, but why?
The point of humiliating someone
is to dehumanise them,
to redefine them.
In other words, to rob them
of their self-perceived identity
and thus, attack their power.
We see these exchanges in Parliament,
and this feeds
the cycle of humiliation
being part of our culture.
We've normalised humiliation.
If we feel humiliated
by our situation,
we seek a group of others to blame
and, unfortunately, humiliate.
We're pack animals,
and so to be socially attractive
is important to us.
have a role in our evolution.
If we have committed
what could be considered a faux pas,
we show embarrassment,
and then we're less
likely to be attacked
by other members of the tribe.
This is why we blush
when we get employee of the month
or are otherwise singled out.
We're saying with that embarrassment,
"Don't attack me."
Shame is something we feel
for something we've done,
and its purpose is similar.
Humiliation is done to us by others,
it is embarrassment
plus shame plus, plus, plus.
And what the plus, plus, plus is
could be defined as loss of face.
We have an idea
of who we are and what we're like,
and when this is challenged
we can experience
a feeling of being obliterated,
a sense of loss of self.
We can even feel humiliated if a
photograph of ourselves is published,
and we have a different image
of ourselves than that photo.
The photo is a threat
to how we want to identify ourselves.
The usual scenario is the humiliator
fears being humiliated,
or already feels humiliated
and powerless,
and the way they seek to regain
their power is to take away power,
to harm the identity of the person
they see as their persecutor.
Men, I believe,
have a particularly tough time of it,
because all over the world they
have been socialised to be...
which usually means suppressing or
denying themselves vulnerable states,
as part of how
they identify themselves.
For example, a lot of men feel
that in order to identify as strong,
they can't be seen to show...
This is a really difficult
self-image to live up to.
When a vulnerability
is exposed by someone,
it may be that the only way that they
can regain their supposed power
is to resort to violence.
It may be this enculturation
of the macho tough guy
being the only desirable image
for a man, that's one of the reasons
that men are many times more
violent and aggressive than women.
But, the violence rarely
ends anything.
It usually leads to more humiliation
and more violence.
We may have a hunger for revenge,
and humiliation
is often a part of revenge.
But the only way to redemption
is to build up our enemies,
not knock them down.
This means, for example,
giving prisoners education,
training and therapy.
Not more punishment and,
therefore, more humiliation,
leading to more anger, more violence.
Maybe we all need to be humiliated
about our habits of humiliation.
We need to readjust until we realise
we have been all too stupid,
lazy, unthinking
and, basically, daft, to carry on
with this winning and losing game.
Will we dare to be vulnerable and say
we don't know the solutions yet,
but humiliation, and otherwise
annihilating the enemy isn't working.
We just might become
less susceptible to humiliation
if we were not so worried about
how others see and experience us.
Let's let go of self-image.
Thanks for watching.
Don't forget to subscribe and click the bell to receive notifications for new videos.
See you again soon!